STEPHANIE WONG: Cloud
Functions gives developers
quite an ideal experience.
You write code, you give
Cloud Functions your code,
and Cloud Functions takes
care of everything else
to run it in a fully managed
production environment,
ready to run thousands of
invocations of your code
at any given time.
One of the defining traits
of serverless platforms,
like Cloud Functions,
is that you get
to focus on writing your code.
The platform handles the rest.
"Serverless" means that these
operations get abstracted away
from the developer experience.
Those abstractions can
also be constraints.
Your code will only go
as far as those use cases
that the underlying
platform can support.
This is why we are introducing
Cloud Functions 2nd generation,
a new version of
Cloud Functions built
to bring new functionality
to the platform.
This means Cloud Functions can
now serve even more developer
use cases, all while
maintaining the same developer
contract and simplicity.
Are you concerned about running
a bit more intensive code
in Cloud Functions?
We've bumped up the
amount of resources
an instance of your
code can use to four
CPUs and 16 gigabytes of RAM.
Do you spend extra time
working through how
to roll out new
versions of your code
to only serve a portion of
requests or invocations?
Cloud Functions 2nd gen makes
this process declarative.
You can now just
tell Cloud Functions
how traffic should be split
between different versions
of your code.
All of this is possible because
Cloud Functions 2nd generation
re-platformed its
underlying infrastructure
to use Google Cloud's
Container Service, Cloud Run.
But don't worry.
Despite this change,
the experience
remains the same for developers.
Write code, and deploy
to Cloud Functions.
Finally, 2nd gen will
also greatly expand
the sources that can trigger
your code's execution.
Over 90-plus event
sources are now
natively supported through
Eventarc, new sources
like BigQuery.
For many of you,
this means that you
won't have to wire
together custom code
to trigger their
code from sources
that previously were not
supported in Cloud Functions.
Whether or not you're
a Cloud Functions pro,
we encourage you to
get started by looking
at our documentation, our
codelab that walks you
through these new features,
or even directly visiting
the Cloud Console, which
has been updated to help you
seamlessly onboard into
deploying your code to Cloud
Functions.
This is Stephanie Wong.